[Applause]
hi Tiffany hi Jane great to see you
tonight we are the second to last
conversation so we we can hold it
together are you handing off the final
baton everybody will win so great
responsibility for us so you were just
talking about systems and connectivity
and I've been wanting to ask you a
question for a while which is that
connected is a very big idea to make a
movie about and I was wondering how did
you find yourself making a movie about
such a big idea did you start with that
idea did it come to you so this film
which I just finished two days ago for
the rough cuts and it used to be called
a declaration of interdependence and you
know thinking about interdependence and
kind of bringing back interdependence as
a way of thought which is really systems
thinking which is what we've been
talking about and then it really so much
of it is shaped today about technology
and just how that word connected is such
a vernacular like let's connect are we
connected and so it really and then it
took on my father who's a writer Leonard
Shlain was co-writing it with my husband
and I and my writing team and then he
started dying of brain cancer in the
middle of making the film so then it
also took on emotional connection and
what does that mean so the word
connected it just feels like what
everything is about
and certainly what the film has become
although the taglines changed it used to
be connected a declaration of
interdependence and now because it has
this autobiographical strand in it we're
trying out connected and autoblog
ography about life death and the pursuit
of technology but we keep changing the
tagline but I like that and you have a
new book oh I do have any book and it's
um it's not a book you have to read in
the sunshine as one of Paul's readers
main thing it's an optimistic
about the future without us this title
is it sounds not optimistic the title is
reality is broken I would think you
would need to make that in this section
right well guess I'm a game designer and
compared to games reality completely
completely broken the tagline for that
the subtitle is why games make us better
and how they can change the world and
that's really I'm looking at the sort of
generation that we have now where the
average young person not only in the US
but but in about in at least 20 other
countries will have amassed 10,000 hours
of playing video games by the time
they're 21 which speaking of Malcolm
Gladwell another great Gladwell Amanda
yeah yeah 10,000 hours they're gonna be
virtuosos at gaming and it seems to me
like that's actually an amazing human
resource that we have we're gonna have
right now we have 500 million people who
play at least an hour a day in an online
game and all these young people who are
this is like the cross-pollination of
ideas I mean that's the that's the part
where at the beginning of if you can
just channel that time and energy and
creativity that they're online or
whatever towards some solving some
problem I mean that's when it gets
incredibly exciting yeah yeah I mean
we're trying right so I make games and I
work with a lot of organizations like
big organizations like the World Bank
Institute the American Heart Association
trying to get gamers to use like a very
particular skill that they have which is
this desire for an epic win so I can
epic win is an outcome that's so
positive it would have seemed ridiculous
until you're right on the verge of
achieving it right nobody would have
believed it was possible but gamers are
really good at that they like it's keep
failing and failing and failing and hang
in there and they're creative I'm an
entrepreneur though yeah they all failed
yeah ultimate entrepreneur ultimate
optimist and so we're trying to figure
out like can we get people to have that
sense of epic win about the real future
not just about virtual worlds but like
what they're capable of and it's so
actually well that reminded me of
something that you sent out
in your newsletter your wonderful
newsletter where you were talking about
the new sun shot that nasa is gonna do I
can't believe it I was dying to hear him
talk about the yeah they've just said
they're gonna do a trip to the Sun and I
thought that was so well liked Icarus I
could I was gonna try to make up like
what is the equivalent of us trying to
go to the Sun which is so yeah I mean
logistically I still don't quite
understand how exactly that will work
but I was thinking when you brought it
up and like first there was the moon
shot and now we're gonna Sun shot to
inspire this kind of epic win thinking
so I was wondering in filmmaking is
there I mean have you observed Sun shot
or a moon shot what what could
filmmakers do in the next 10 or 50 years
that would be that that big of a step
forward well the film used to be such an
expensive craft that it was this really
you know only few people did it was so
expensive and only and there was so few
gatekeepers that decided who make films
so to be alive today when the
democratization of the equipment and in
my films are mostly archival and
animation so for me it's like a kid in
the candy store with like the amount of
footage I'm able to gleam that's on the
Internet my fantasy is like everything
on YouTube is high-res and Creative
Commons and you can just be mashing up
every aspect of culture into something
new so too I guess it comes back to what
we're talking about earlier the
collaborative aspect film is ultimately
collaborative I mean I'm making
connected with my husband Canon I was
doing with my father and I've got a
great team of like 8 people it's so
collaborative so if you scale that
outward that's so exciting
collaborative filmmaking with people
from other countries and adding footage
and we're all uploading it online and
you know they have all these
collaborative tools now where you can be
editing in real time with other people I
do that with my art director and in
Portland and it's the tools are there
the people are gonna be online so I
guess the epic win would if we made
really made like a global film like I
don't know how many people that would
entail but there's a couple experiments
right now where people were asked to
upload footage from all over the world
and Sundance is doing it there's another
one
just happened but that's very that's the
ultimate extension of collaboration for
filmmaking yeah okay so now I'm going to
that's what my brain will will muse on
now it's like what is that epic film and
I love the term the epic win it's so
like male I don't know if yeah feels to
be like a epic win I don't know my
brother used to wear that epic in high
school oh yeah I mean you're trying to
get that heart like there's something
like there's an irrational mythic
quality right the warrior yeah epic
winning yeah yes yeah but you're doing
some of the collaboration like that kind
of global creativity sourcing yeah yeah
be right yeah we're doing we're doing
experiment I really I just feel like me
and my team we're like throwing
spaghetti against the like receding wall
of the web we're just trying to do all
these experiments with we did this thing
at the commencement speech where we
asked people to upload their ideas of
the future from all over the world
graduates from all over the world and
then we're doing this experiment now
we're asking designers from all over
design the movie poster based on some
images from it so yeah we're really into
this kind of cross-pollination of ideas
from different places and how the web
can facilitate that okay so now we do a
game together I was gonna say okay so
game designer internet connect connected
media guru there's something together
well now we have a few minutes at least
I'm sure to just figure out what we're
gonna do ten minutes work it all out and
so well here's actually so syncing so
you know being here today throughout the
long conversation and thinking about how
amazing these two chairs are and
interesting people come up and they go
out I was thinking like what if we could
do some big connected version of this or
some big game like could we put two
chairs in public and see if we could how
long can we keep a conversation going
and I was thinking the rule would be
that once you sit down you can't get up
you have to stay in conversation with
somebody until someone comes to take
your place and we could see how long we
could keep I love this idea and one time
Ken and I went to
and we were out in the middle of nowhere
on the playa and we saw this guy beating
this drum and and we went up to him and
he's like oh I'm so glad you're here now
I can go we were there for a really long
time
so I could almost see this long
conversation came here but I liked that
idea of if you like stream it you stream
it so there's some kind of video
component where people are watching
because when people are watching they're
not gonna get it from the chair right
right well what about this component as
the conversation is happening you've got
some video jockeys online who are
linking to relevant visuals to go with
what they're talking about
you could be hyper linking out to other
kind of systems that require people not
to get up or you know other vit you know
so they'd be kind of visual visual
jockeys on YouTube or calling up videos
that have to do with the conversation so
it's visually stimulating also seems
like it could be a useful thing I mean
to to sit down across from somebody I
mean we're doing this kind of like
little mini experiment where I think
most people haven't over prepared we're
just gonna we assume that we're all
thinking big thoughts and we all care
about something's gonna come out right
and I love the idea of just taking like
random people in the street and they
have 20 minutes to have a conversation
on the Internet in front of everybody
and it seems like that feeds indirectly
today I mean the whole you know 15
minutes of this is your intellectual 15
20 minutes
see and now maybe we could bring it down
to 15 yeah it's the kind of yeah I think
I could work I think it'd be interesting
I mean I think well there's this kind of
exhibitionism that certainly is
happening she said pornographic
information I thought it was a great way
to describe it but but there's also this
beautiful thing which I think everyone
gets to feel like they've got some way
to get their perspective heard I was
just looking at this archival image for
the movie of all these
kids look like I like it it's a shot
from the 70s and the Soviet Union
they're all holding up their paintings
they're like seven years old house and
they're all proudly showing the painting
they did and in some level you know
that's the ultimate human expect
everyone wants to say Here I am
this is my perspective and it matters I
think on some level that's what the
internet is providing this way for
people to feel like they're heard and
and I think with the social and internet
interest graphs you know going out to
find people with commonality there -
yeah what was really interesting what we
were saying earlier about the oxytocin
and and Twitter and how we're feeling
more bonded and trusting and more
generous maybe because of Twitter so
that idea of a declaration of
interdependence I mean do you think
they'll be like a generational I just
shifted I I do I think that people I do
I mean with this new film we're going to
have on our website people to sign a
declaration of interdependence which we
gonna marry yeah well we're gonna make
it kind of open-source what does that
mean to you because it means different
things to different people but we'll do
a weekly newsletter that'll give ideas
on how you can incorporate
interdependent thinking into your life
so it'll be a mix of actual things you
can do things to think about books to
read but I do think the next generation
you know this kind of idea that power
expands the moment you share it and on
the internet you know you're just you're
sharing information and and ideas and
that's power and that's I I guess I I
feel like though that there was actually
in the in the Week in Review about three
weeks ago they some I can't remember who
did the study but it was talking about
how the Internet is opening up more
businesses that are based on
collaboration whether it's Zipcar or all
these new businesses are starting based
on sharing and I do think that that is
born from the web and that generosity
and what I like you know this kind of
global hits of oxytocin but see the
thing that oxytocin is when you get a
hug you need to hug for six seconds
before the the rush happens so I don't
know is you have to like be clicking
some connection for long enough
but everything's gettin so short but I
do get hacked by the way like six
seconds so when I hug somebody I should
be you gotta be waiting success to get
that rush yeah that's a really actually
it's very but but the younger generation
I do I do think I have a lot of young
people on my team and the way that they
think about collaborating it's just it's
the first thing they think of
yeah and do you think that's I mean
hearing hearing you say that it sounds
kind of subversive and you think the
original Declaration of Independence and
there's such a kind of I don't that that
feeling of like go it alone and it's
your life it used to be such I was such
a part of our country and you know I
think it's been the human you know
declare interdependence were separate
we're our own and I I feel like this
moment that we're at is going to be to
be recognizing our interdependence
through resources through knowledge and
information through you know the way
that we do business it has to be it has
to be so that to me is the you know
bringing back systems thinking is you
can't believe how many people do I mean
like when Paul was saying it's the way
we're born I mean it's this kind of
pattern thinking and we have so much
data now and so much computing power
that we can finally see these patterns
that we never could see before it's
looking for the systems in the pattern
so I we're only going to be doing that
more yeah with your games I mean that's
about pattern-seeking and so we just
launched a new organization called game
fall which is like playful but gonna be
like mindful oh that's better
okay no no I like mostly because I'm
whenever people here make games or and
they see research about babies I think
I'll be excited and I'm totally not
excited at all because I don't like play
because play is well it isn't the
difference between playing games I guess
is that games are structured and and
have a goal and I'm very interested in
sort of identifying these epic win goals
so that we can because they seem to
motivate a more
so we called a gameful because we don't
really have a word for that full yeah
like really wholehearted highly
motivated self-directed trying to
achieve something amazing right which is
I think is a is I think game I mean it's
so interesting because I your work to me
it goes above game I mean it's
interesting this stigma I mean words the
power of words and game you know I do
have this framework of what a game is
and you're really kind of crowdsourcing
intelligence with some of your your
games yeah whether it's world with that
oil or like these bigger ideas so what
about changing the word game oh gosh you
know somebody somebody just asked me
that I was at Stanford this week and
speaking of the sophomore class and it's
this girl asked like how do we get over
the bias what would be a better word
than game and you know I think we're
totally kind of screwed up by the moment
in history that we're in which is that
games for the past 30 years have been
this digital format and for maybe 20 of
those years 15 of those years they were
alike not collaborative or collective or
so I think you gotta come up with a new
word you know you've been around over
here you're gonna reclaim game and make
sure people know the Mayans had games I
mean with that would be stupid to just
have there been abandoned but different
Mayans but have there been games for
okay yes there have been games
throughout history but have there been
games that have truly been about solving
world social ills or world problems or
have games always been about this kind
of have there been I mean you would know
yeah no I mean some people would say it
this sort of that false story about the
Olympics being games to create peace but
that wasn't I guess historically why
they did it they were there were other
reasons they didn't actually care about
the peace part that was just to help the
games happen no no I think I think
you're right it's true that we're kind
of gaming with a purpose now or yeah
sexy it's not sexy aiming with a purpose
needs to be like a you know it feels
like there's because you are doing
something that's well no I mean I'm all
for reclaiming words and kind of
teaching people the new definition yeah
well I'm part of it is you know
trying to get young people to feel that
they can do something that matters right
if you there's a great huge study by Pew
Internet life research group a couple
years ago 99 percent of boys under the
age of 18 in the u.s. play video games
regularly a 94 percent of girls do right
so this is a generation that like that's
where the heart is so I want to use the
word games because I want Anna to get
involved and then to see that that
everything they've learned about
collaborating online everything they can
be applied there the greater good yeah
yeah so so for them the word should work
and for the rest of us we need to be and
perhaps with the next year for the next
long conversation we will have chairs
out front and we'll see we'll do an
experiment 24 hours we'll run it but we
will enable and empower the players to
actually run it as long as I can keep
going maybe it'll go for a month it
would be pretty epic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you